Jack we talked with filmmaker joe wilson
of the vampire mom and we did a video
interview series with him and he was
adamant that no one can make a viral
video hmm what's your take on that yeah
I don't think well I think it's probably
the same thing about like you know like
no one can necessarily go out and make a
hit or you know go out make a monster
hit like that's what that's what they
want you to do go out and make something
uber successful but I don't think you
can necessarily manufacture something to
be viral I think it's like the thing
about it's like I've always said you
can't something that's cool because it
is the second anybody tries to be cool
it's it's automatically uncool you know
like straight away that you can tell
when somebody is trying to manufacture
so to try to create something or
engineer something to be viral I think
most people will smell that as being
inauthentic and I think the thing that
creates a viral thing is something that
somebody feels that they've captured
something and then just has to share it
because whatever it is about that thing
is so weird or so special or so whatever
and I think most people can detect if
something is reverse engineered to be at
that idea of a reverse engineering is
something that's thrown around in this
digital space like you cannot reverse
engineer a viral video what you can try
to do is is create something that is
real or interesting enough and hope that
it becomes viral I think I don't know I
be interesting to find out who's like
sat down and like you know strategically
made something and if it went viral if
they would even reveal that information
like ha ha ha we got you we made this
like Frankenstein you know but I don't
know i don't personally i don't think
it's that's that's the way to do it
you